hallo ihr lieben heute machen wir mal
eine zitrone rolle und für eine
biskuitrolle ich finde dass die immer
wieder in vergessenheit gerät und dies
so einfach und schnell hergestellt und
schmeckt außerdem super lecker was und
zum wetter und zum sommer gibt es jetzt
eben eine zitrone rolle und ich zeige
euch mit der zeit immer wieder
verschiedene varianten und verschiedene
geschmacksrichtungen
wir starten zuallererst mit dem
biskuitteig und dafür benötigen wir alle
auf zimmertemperatur lauwarmes wasser
mehlspeise stärke zucker außerdem etwas
backpulver und eine bio zitrone damit
unsere biscuit masse gleich richtig
schön locker wird müssen wir die eier
aufschlagen und zwar so dass die richtig
an wohnungen dazu gewinnen da hilft
unser wasser das geht noch mal dass ich
es richtig schön aufschlägt und vor
allem unser zucker und die drei zutaten
gehen jetzt in die küchenmaschine und
schlagen das 68 minuten lang
[Musik]
die eier zu kamaz ist jetzt richtig
schön cremig und sehr voluminös gewonnen
doch genau richtig so ich hab jetzt acht
minuten in der küchenmaschine gebraucht
mit dem handrührgerät braucht ihr circa
zehn bis elf minuten also nehmt euch da
auf jeden fall die zeit und den zitronen
abhielt habe ich hier auch schon rein
gegeben allerdings nur den von der
halben zitrone die andere hälfte gehe
ich gleich nämlich noch in die creme ist
übrigens ganz wichtig dass es eine bio
zitrone ist so und jetzt machen wir
weiter mit den trockenen zutaten und die
sibe ich jetzt einmal hinein
[Musik]
wurde trockenen zutaten sind wird drin
und jetzt sind wir das nochmal auf
niedriger stufe nur so lange bis es
gerade so verbunden ist also nicht zu
lange sondern einfach nur schauen wenn
es verbunden ist dann ist der teig
fertig
[Musik]
so der teig ist fertig und ich habe
jetzt hier meinen backfisch bereitgelegt
mit backpapier ausgekleidet und wer mag
kann da jetzt noch einen wackler am drum
herum legen dann sind ja abschluss auch
schon gerade das müsst ihr aber nicht
fand sie also keinen eckigen back haben
darauf könnt ihr das auch weglassen ist
gar kein problem
und jetzt wollen wir den tag einmal ein
und wie gesagt hier die variante ohne
back kram das heißt sie können das auch
ganz normal in eurem backblech der vor
anrufen geeignet ist backen und dann
wird er auch ein bisschen dünner und
nicht so dick ich zeig euch gleich beide
endergebnisse so den teig habe ich jetzt
noch mal schön glatt verstrich mit einem
winkel palette und jetzt kommt er in den
vorgeheizten backofen bei 190 grad ober
und unterhitze so ungefähr zwölf bis
vierzehn minuten schaut einfach mal das
ist schön goldbraun ist macht gerne die
stäbchen probe und dann wählen wir uns
gleich wieder so der biscuit boden ist
gebacken ganze 12 minuten hat das bei
mir gibt dauert einfach mal bei euch
dass es wie gesagt nicht zu dunkel wird
damit es auch nicht so hart wird
und jetzt brauchen wir ein weiteres
küchentuch und etwas zucker oder
puderzucker ich ihm gerne puderzucker
weil ich diese zuckerkristalle auf
meinem biscuit boden nicht so sehr mag
und jetzt machen wir folgendes in dem
uns ein sie und gm puderzucker komplett
auf das küchentuch
[Musik]
so wenn ihr das dann erledigt habt gebt
ihr euren noch heißen bizkit boden
einmal umgedreht auf das küchenteam
wollen nämlich die schöne form gleich
oben haben deshalb müssen das ganze
jetzt einmal umdrehen und jetzt einfach
das backpapier abziehen
[Applaus]
und weil der whisky boden auch an der
oberfläche immer ganz schnell trocken
wird und wir das verhindern möchten
brauchen wir jetzt noch küchenrolle und
das habe ich gerade nass gemacht einfach
ganz kurz unterm leitungswasser und hab
es dann einmal ausgeführt sagt man das
so anders aus bringen
das wort immer so gut auf jeden fall
gehen wir das jetzt auch unseren whisky
boden ihr könnt natürlich auch ein
zweites küchentuch nehmen das nass
machen und darauf geben wenn ihr ein
star habt ganz wie ihr möchtet
[Musik]
so dass freue mich jetzt an die seite
und in der zwischenzeit machen unsere
leckere zitronencreme fertig wir
benötigen kalte schlagsahne außerdem
magerquark beide zutaten sind kalt
direkt aus dem kühlschrank außerdem
seine stand mittel und puderzucker
hier habe ich den restlichen abrieb der
bio zitrone von vorhin und davon
brauchen wir außerdem noch etwas saft
die zitronencreme ist super einfach weil
ich kennt weiß dass ich einfach und
raffinierte claims liebe in dem es ganz
einfach quark und sahne in unsere
rührschüssel entweder die küchenmaschine
oder das handrührgerät ist vollkommen
egal wichtig ist nur das wie gesagt
diese beiden zutaten kalte direkt aus
dem kühlschrank kommen
dazu gebe ich jetzt noch vor der zucker
und den abtrieb der zitronenschale
dazu noch einen kleinen spritzer
zitronensaft so das reicht schon
und jetzt bei niedriger stufe ganz
leicht miteinander verrühren so dass
sich das verbindet und dann kommt unser
seine stadt mittel dazu und wird auch
volle power richtig schön steif
geschlagen
fertig das war schon so schnell einfach
gegen krim
jetzt will ich kam ein bisschen boden
und dann wird das ganze fertiggestellte
bizkit boden ist jetzt schön ausgekühlt
das ist auch ganz wichtig denn wenn der
noch lauwarm wäre dann wird ja unsere
sonne schmelzen und das brauchen wir
überhaupt nicht sind nicht gerade die
tücher ab das tuch also dass küchentuch
das bleibt auf jeden fall da das braucht
ihr gleich zum einrollen und die krähen
wird jetzt ganz einfach auf dem boden
verteilt
[Musik]
beim parteien der creme solltet ihr
jetzt nur darauf achten dass vorne beim
teig 2 cm des biscuit bodens frei
bleiben denn sobald ihr das ganze
aufrollt drückt der boden die creme nach
vorne und dann verhinderte dass das
ganze überläuft
sobald wir dann alles schön verstrichen
habt das ganze aufgeräumt wie gesagt mit
hilfe des küchenteams und da arbeitet
ihr euch jetzt ganz einfach von vorne
nach hinten rollt immer wieder ein schön
fest das ganze eben eine rolle ergibt
und nach dem aufräumen ist die zitronen
biskuitrolle auch schon fertig die muss
gar nicht erst in den kühlschrank kann
sofort serviert werden aber eine
entscheidende sache fehlt noch und zwar
die deko und das macht ihr ganz einfach
wenn ihr mit puderzucker durch ein sieg
gibt sind sie das ganze schon wunderbar
aus
[Musik]
und hier seht ihr noch mal zum vergleich
die biskuitrolle mit dem bug kam diesen
ticken dicker also der teig als der ohne
back raum wirklich ein feiner
unterschied und da könnt ihr einfach je
nach geschmack gucken und ihr seht also
wenn ihr kein sakrament ist es auch
überhaupt kein problem
[Musik]
so und jetzt probiere ich natürlich noch
mal für euch ich weiß dass der boden
supersoft ist ich meine wenn bei der
biskuitrolle den whisky boden ich weiß
ist das macht die ganze rolle keinen
sinn des hat ist das also detail ist das
geheimnis sage ich immer die füllung ist
sowieso super lecker da wir nicht sehr
von überzeugt die von des vorbeters du
bist doch hinter der kamera du musst
auch aufnehmen
nächste junge mutter zu mir kommen zehn
von zehn gehen wir davon aus ist nicht
so kurzfristige leute wie wir ihn ist
nicht zwei stücke auf einem teller
steinreich die rolle für 14 bis 16
personen
superlecker wenn ihr euch mal forscher
diese rollen die ich zu kaufen gibt
diesen so claudia nur zu dritt geteilt
und waren nicht satt vorher das war
wirklich so und die ist wirklich
unglaublich groß schnell hergestellt
ihr kriegt viele leute satt und vor
allem wenn ihr mal spontan besuchen
könnt ihr das gut am gleichen tag noch
zu bereiten oder wenn ihr möchtet auch
am vortag des vollkommen euch überlassen
so die genauen mengenangaben hier unten
in der infobox ich freue mich über fotos
mit dem hashtag ins kittchen ob
instagram lasst den video gerne in
münchen nach oben da wenn es euch
gefallen hat hinterlässt er ein
kostenloses abo dann verpasst ja auch
nichts mehr
und dann sehen wir uns auch beim
nächsten mal wieder
[Musik]